-Okay, hi.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Jungkook.
Nice to meet you guys.
-Yeah, that's right.
Good to see you, buddy.
♪♪
-Hey, guys, I'm here with BTS.
And we're gonna try out
the Fortnite Dance Challenge.
You guys up for it?
-Uh-huh.
-Let's go!
♪♪
-Oh, yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you okay?
Are you okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now BTS is gonna show me
the Idol dance.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-1, 2, 3, 4...
-...5, 6, 7, 8.
-Here we go. Ready?
-5, 6, 7, 8!
-♪ Oh-oh, ooh-oh, hey! ♪
♪ Oh-oh, ooh-oh, ooh-oh ♪
-I'm in! I'm in the band!
I'm in the band! Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Before BTS existed,
what did you want to be?
Jungkook, how about you?
-My dream was pro gamer.
-Pro gamer.
-A gamer?
-Yeah.
-First impressions -- What did
you think of each other
when you first got together?
-I saw RM.
-Yeah.
-And then I thought --
-What did you think of him?
-He was amazing.
-Oh, thank you.
But Jungkook --
When I first saw him,
I was only wearing
the underwear.
-Yeah.
-Wait. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa. What?
You were only wearing underwear?
-I mean in the house.
In my home.
-What?
-He came, like,
"Oh, I'm the new member."
I was, like,
only wearing panties and...
Yeah.
That was the first impression.
-So, who put this together?
You?
-No. I was just, like, the first
member for this group and --
-You were?
-Yeah.
-Number two?
-Three.
-Who's three?
-Suga, you came in.
What happened?
How did you hear?
-We were boys.
[ Laughs ]
Do you remember the first time
you ever performed
in front of a crowd,
and what was that like?
-It was our debut showcase.
Uh, there were about 200
to 300 people.
-300 people.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Now you have billions of people
watching.
But 300 people meant a lot
to you, right?
-Right. Of course.
-I still can never forget it.
Everything happened so fast,
and it was overwhelming.
-It was?
-Yeah.
-And I cried after the show.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-Everyone cried.
-Everyone cried?
-Yes.
-Yeah, because it's a big thing.
Is there any audience
that you want to grab
that you haven't got
the opportunity to meet yet?
-John Cena.
-John Cena?
-We want to see him.
He's a big fan of us, and...
We're the big fan, and, like --
-Really?
-Mutually. Of course!
-He likes J-Hope.
-Yeah. He loves J-Hope.
-John Cena.
-Yeah, we were always watching,
like, WWE,
like, when we were like,
you know, 13...
-John Cena!
[ All vocalizing theme music ]
♪♪
-Yeah.
-Alright.
I'm gonna get you hooked up
with John Cena.
I'm gonna make sure it happens.
Is there something you do
before every performance?
Can you show me?
-You want to do it together?
-I'll do it with you.
-Okay.
-Come here.
-So...we go down.
We don't go up.
So we'll go down.
And when I say...
[ Speaking Korean ]
And you guys say...
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-You say...
[ Speaking Korean ]
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-Yeah.
-When I say...
[ Speaking Korean ]
you say...[ Speaking Korean ]
Okay? And we go down.
[ Speaking Korean ]
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-Yeah!
-Oh, come on!
-Go!
[ BTS oohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, SUGA!
-Wow! Wow!
[ Rubber duck squeaking ]
-Jungkook wins.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-Whoo!
-Go?
-Go, go, go!
♪♪
[ BTS ohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Come on! Come on!
-Winner!
-Jungkook wins.
-Go, go, go.
-Let's go! Oh.
-No faces. No faces. No faces.
-Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
-No faces. No faces.
-Go, go, go. Go, go, go.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Bell dinging ]
-Who won? Who won? Who won?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
-20, let's get it.
-21.
-Not 21.
-I'm not touching that one.
-[ Laughs ]
-1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20...24.
-The winner!
-Jungkook wins!
-The new movie out,
called "Break the Silence,"
it's in select theaters now.
And you just announced
the new album, "BE."
-"BE."
-Did we?
-Me? Me?
-No, not "me." "BE."
-Not "me."
"BE."
[ Laughter ]
Jungkook,
when you were in high school,
the band was actually
at your high-school graduation.
-Yeah.
-Go!
-Go, go, go, go!
[ Laughter ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Bell dings ]
-Jungkook wins.
-Go!
-Alright, here we go.
13 seconds.
We got 10 seconds.
-[ Speaks Korean ]
-My gosh. Jimin, hurry up!
-Oh.
[ Indistinct talking ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Men speaking Korean ]
-Jimin, you're such a cheater.
[ Chuckles ]
-Jungkook wins.
-Go!
-Whoa!
-Oh!
-Oh, oh.
-Oh! Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
This is great, man.
Two seconds. Hurry up.
[ Bell dings ]
Oh, that's it.
Time out. Time out.
Stop shaking.
No more shaking.
Let's count up...
-Wow.
-...how many each player got.
-J.K.
One, two, three, four...
Yo, 49. 49.
-49?
-RM with 47!
-47. Whoa.
-Winner is...
-Oh, by two picks?
[ Bell dings ]
The winner is Jungkook!
-Jungkook is the champion.
My thanks to BTS.
Stick around.
We got more "Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Come on back.
♪♪
Jin and Jungkook,
tell me about creating the "A,"
because that doesn't look easy
for me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Men speaking Korean ]
-Okay, let's go.
-Yeah! Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about.
-Let's go. Let's go.
-Ah.
-Easy.
-Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
-Yes.
-Too easy. Too easy.
-Lemon squeezy.
-It wasn't hard.
-[ Laughs ]
You get it in one take, yeah.
-Jungkook, you know I'd never
mess around with you, bud.
Let's see what this
has to say here.
-Will 10 scoops of ice cream
fit in a taco shell?
-Taco shell?
-[ Indistinct talking ]
-I think it's too small,
though, but...
-[ Speaks Korean ]
-Let's go.
-Ah!
10 scoops into a taco shell.
Do not break the shell.
You have to be very careful.
-Okay, J.K.,
let's go, let's go.
-Alright, Jungkook, go.
-Go.
-Let's go. Let's go, J.K.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Jung-scoop.
-That's good.
That's one scoop.
-Okay.
-Two.
-That's good.
That counts. That's two scoop.
-Three.
-Oh, he's mixing the flavors.
Look at this.
-Scoop, scoop.
-That's five.
You're halfway there.
-Almost there.
Almost there. Come on.
-Oh, yeah.
-Nine.
-Last one.
Last, last, last.
Jung-scoop!
-Jungkook.
-J-scoop.
-Ooh, ooh.
-Yes! My man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how he got the nickname.
Yes, and he ate some, too.
-Thank you for coming
back to the show.
-Yeah.
-You have
so many accomplishments.
I want to run through them
so right now we understand
what's happening here.
First of all, since the last
time you were on our show,
BTS has been nominated
for five Grammys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your single "Seven" made history
by being the fastest song
in history
to reach 1 billion streams.
1 billion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A few weeks ago, you replaced
yourself on Spotify's list
of most streamed songs
in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now your debut solo album
"Golden" is out
and it's already
breaking all sorts of records.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
I have news for you.
I have news for you that I don't
even know if you know this yet.
This just happened an hour ago.
Your single "Seven" just became
platinum right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on now!
Just happened!
♪♪
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-How does it all feel?
Are these things
that you imagined were possible?
-You...
You really make it sound
like I'm a huge global pop star.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, yeah. This helps.
Yes, yes, I think you are.
I think you are, yeah.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Yeah.
The best fans.
Before we get into the album,
I want to learn more about you.
When you're not breaking records
and being a global pop star,
what do you like doing?
Outside of music,
what do you do for fun?
-I think...
uh, it's -- hmm.
Pretty ordinary,
like many people.
Like, sometimes I spend
my whole day in bed.
[ Laughter ]
Or cooking.
-Ooh, cooking?
-Working out.
-Yeah.
[ Crowd cheers ]
What do you cook?
What do you like to cook?
-Do you know...
[ Crowd cheers ]
-No.
-Noodle.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
I love noodles, yes.
Yes, I know that. You slurp?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the way to do it.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Alright.
Yes, I will do that.
But also I heard that you like
making your own pizza.
-Pizza. Ah. Yeah.
-Yeah?
-I like pizza, but...
I didn't like leftovers, so...
-So like cold pizza, no good?
-Yeah.
-Well, have you ever had
New York City pizza?
-Not yet.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Oh!
-I got you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got you. It's not cold.
-New York pizza!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is one of my favorite --
This is one of my favorite --
-Your favorite?
-Yeah. This is what I like.
This is Joe's Pizza.
-Let's cheers.
-Cheers, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Mmm.
-That's good, right?
-Yum!
-Yeah. I'm talking about!
I have more questions for you.
I was looking through
some interviews with you,
and this question made me laugh.
It said, what is
the scariest thing in the world?
The scariest thing
in the world for you,
and your answer was...
Does anyone know?
-Microwave!
-Yes, a microwave.
[ Laughter ]
A microwave.
"I always worry
that it will explode."
What are you talking about?
-Well, when I was young...
-Yeah.
-I used to be afraid, but...
Still afraid.
[ Laughter ]
-Why? Why are you afraid?
-I don't know.
-[ Laughs ]
I guess it's a little
frightening,
because I don't
really understand it.
-I don't know, like...
-Yeah.
-Boom.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, nothing is going to happen.
No, nothing's going to happen.
Nothing is going to happen.
You'll be fine with
the microwave, but I understand.
I don't understand
how it does get warmer,
but maybe I'll research that
and I'll learn.
I was looking that you go
on this livestream sometimes
and I'm going to --
[ Crowd cheers ]
Is it called Weverse?
-Yeah, Weverse.
-Weverse, yeah, is
the livestream.
And sometimes you do karaoke.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Sometimes you're cooking.
This thing that made me laugh,
this is my favorite
thing you did.
You fell asleep.
[ Crowd cheers ]
And you fell asleep
and just slept for 45 minutes.
And everyone, 6 million people
tuned in to watch you sleep.
[ Cheering continues ]
Did you -- What did you --
Did you feel sleepy going in?
What happened?
-I think my fans, ARMY,
liked it because...
[ Crowd cheers ]
It was something
very unexpected, but...
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, yes.
I want to do this too.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's so funny.
I think it's great.
I'm going to try this.
Yeah, I know, and we'll see
how many people tune in
to watch me sleep, but I snore,
so it's going to be rough.
-I'll see you.
-Okay. You'll watch? Thanks.
I appreciate it.
Since you've been with the band,
this is the 10-year
anniversary of BTS.
[ Crowd cheers ]
And you guys have been so nice
to come on our show.
And thank you very much
for always coming on our show.
We appreciate it.
I was going to ask you
what's one thing
that you're most proud of?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's cool that
you stay humble.
I want to talk "Golden."
Congrats on this.
I want to know
about the album title.
Now, a lot of "Golden" -- Is
that a nickname for you, right?
[ Crowd cheers ]
Golden Maknae. What does that
mean, Golden Maknae?
-It means "golden youngest."
-Okay, yeah.
-Of the group in Korean.
-Yeah. And so you --
That stuck with you, Golden?
And you knew
that was going to be
the title of the album
always if you went solo?
[ Crowd cheers ]
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it's a great cover.
Great cover. By the way,
look at those abs. Yeah.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Never, never. I'll never --
I'll never achieve that, ever.
I love the album.
It's fun.
I will say the first half
is very kind of fun.
It's, you know,
it's Jack Harlow.
Major Lazer.
It's kind of poppy and fun.
Second half gets
kind of more serious.
Some are sad,
sadder than others.
Is that what you wanted?
Do you want to be
that versatile?
Yeah, I think you did it.
I think you did it.
-Did it!
-Do you --
Do you run any of the songs
by your bandmates?
The rest of BTS?
Because we had Jimin
on the show,
and he told me that --
[ Crowd cheers ]
He told me that he runs
his songs by you guys
before he releases them.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. They're nice.
Yeah. You're family. Yeah.
Can we say that there may be a
Golden world tour in the future?
[ Crowd cheers ]
Yeah.
If you need an opening act,
I can do two or three songs.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-Please.
-Yeah.
Let's talk about the song
you're performing,
"Standing Next to You,"
later in the show.
What does that song mean to you?
[ Crowd cheers ]
Is there a little choreography
from "Standing Next to You" that
you could teach me?
-Yeah, of course.
-You could teach me?
-Let's do it. Let's do it.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-What do I do?
-Okay.
So simple.
-One. Two. Three. Four.
Oh, yeah.
Bam, bam.
♪ Standing next to you ♪
Bam!
[ Crowd cheering ]
-I don't know if --
No, yeah, alright.
-One, two, three, four.
Bam, bam.
♪ Standing next to you ♪
[ Grunts ]
[ Crowd cheers ]
-I can't do that. I can't.
Can I get a beat maybe?
-You can do it.
♪♪
-One, two, three,
four, five, six.
♪ Standing next to you ♪
♪ Bah ♪
[ Crowd cheers ]
Jungkook, everybody!
"Golden" is out now.
And later Jungkook
will be performing
"Standing Next to You."
Stick around, everybody!
Jungkook.
-Hey, Jimmy.
♪♪
-What are you doing?
-Standing next to you.
Pretty good, right?
-Yeah. Sure.
Stay golden, Jimmy.
[ Ding! ]
-[ Muffled ] Jungkook.
You're coming back,
right?